good morning john i wasn't gonna do this
but then i saw a former head of the sec
on cnbc comparing the freaking gamestop
short squeeze to the siege on the
capitol and i got too mad
and so now i'm here i think it's fairly
easy to pull back the curtain here and
talk about
why this happened why doesn't mean you
shouldn't have faith in the stock market
and why it is
nothing like the siege on the capitol
gamestop is a mall retailer that sells
video games and so
it's been struggling its current
business model is not well suited
to a pandemic or the future in general a
bunch of finance people notice this not
a complicated thing to notice
and they want to make money off of that
now they may not own gamestop stock they
didn't buy it when it was high so they
can't really sell it
when it's low they could buy it low and
sell it lower but the way to really make
money off this
is to make a bet to bet that it will go
down a certain amount in a certain
amount of time and just like in vegas
when your bet gets more specific your
payout if you win will be higher they
then make these bets public
the rest of the market sees it and
actually drives the price of the stock
down
but then someone notices that gamestop
isn't actually doing that poorly they're
sitting on a fair amount of cash people
are coming in and buying ps5s they're
not doing well but they're not going
bankrupt so those people
start to buy gamestop stock and then it
stops crashing the people who made the
bets
get worried so they make more bets so
that the market will see that and they
will lower the price again and this
works
for an amount of time they do it so much
that they actually it turns out
have made promises to buy more gamestop
stock than exists on the market someone
notices this and they say a fairly
simple sentence
the finance guys have promised to buy so
much gamestop stock
that if it doesn't go bankrupt or get
purchased by a private equity fund
in the next like three months they're
going to have to buy gamestop stock
at whatever the price is and we can be
the ones selling it to them
at whatever the price is other people
hear that and they're like you know what
you're right so they do that they start
to push the price of the stock up
probably closer to what it actually
should be worth considering that the
company's not going bankrupt and then
the stock starts to increase in value
a lot and that becomes news and that
brings more people in whether they
understand what's going on or not and at
some point here this starts to
transition from squeezing value out of
hedge funds
to just a little mini pyramid scheme
buying the stock because people are
buying the stock and then trying to get
more people to buy the stock so you can
sell the stock when it's higher because
eventually the price of gamestop is
going to go back down to a rational
number from even the most optimistic
perspective gamestop is worth
10 times less what it's trading at right
now as long as you're still squeezing
the hedge funds it's about that not
about the price but eventually those
squeezes run out and it has to go back
down to a normal price that is
eventually going to happen and on the
way down
people are gonna lose a lot of money now
for everyone involved in this this was a
gamble this was not
investment if you go into the discords
where these things are organized it's
just a bunch of people bullying each
other not to sell while slowly selling
in the background to make sure they've
locked their profits
also it's very exciting and for certain
brains mine included
that kind of feedback is dangerous and
addictive
and we've seen the exuberance of this
sort of like explode out into other
places like there wasn't a
like fundamental weird reason why
dogecoin
was suddenly worth more the important
thing here is that this instability was
not created by reddit
it was created by hedge funds who
promised to buy more stock than existed
there are some real terrible arcane
systems for manipulating our world
for the benefit of like the worst people
and it's just
people it's not magic it's decipherable
and none of it has much to do with how
the market actually works which is that
people buy shares in companies that they
think are doing well and will do better
and
sell shares in companies that they think
will not do well now these
manipulating agencies should be
regulated out of existence they
shouldn't be able to do what they do but
instead
at least in this one way they got memed
out of existence that door has been
slammed in their face by a few hundred
people
who figured something out and a few
million people who were mobilized in a
financial action unlike anyone has ever
seen
ever in the world eventually people are
going to figure out how powerful they
are
it'll be interesting to see what we do
with that john i'll see you on tuesday